in this video i explain the log rank
test we will go through what a log rank
test is and how it is calculated
the formulas used are from the very
recommendable book survival analysis by
david g kleinbaum and mitchell klein
and with that i would say let's start
with the first question
what is the log rank test
the log rank test is used in survival
time analysis
and compares the distribution of time to
occurrence of an event of two or more
independent samples
but now step by step
what does distribution mean
what does time
until an event occurs mean and what does
two or more independent samples mean
let's start from the back i would say
with two or more independent samples
with the log rank test you can test if
there is a difference between two or
more different groups
for example whether there is a
difference between two different
materials used for a dental filling
now the next question is in terms of
what is there a difference
the log rank test analyzes whether there
is a difference in the time until an
event occurs
now what does time until an event occurs
mean
the log rank test looks at the variable
that has a start time and when a certain
event occurs an end time
the time between the start time and the
event is considered in the log rank test
the time can be measured in days weeks
or months
in our example we might be interested in
whether the material has an influence on
the time after which the filling breaks
out again
so we have a start point the moment when
the filling is inserted
and we have an end point or event
which is the time when the filling
breaks out again
we are interested in the time between
the start and the end that is the time
between the insertion of the filling and
the breaking out of the filling
and how do we compare the times until
the fitting breaks out again
we do this with the help of the
kepler-maya curve or with the table that
is used to create this graph
here the time is entered on the x-axis
and the survival rate on the y-axis
what is the survival rate
the kepler-meyer curve tells you how
likely it is that a filling will last
longer than a certain time
let's say you want to know how likely it
is that a feeling will last longer than
let's say 5 years
then you can read from the kaplan-meier
curve that it is 70 likely that a
feeling will last longer than 5 years
but now we want to check whether there
is a difference between two materials so
we enter both curves in the chart the
question that the log rank test now
answers is is there a significant
difference between the two curves
or in other words does the filling
material have an influence on the
survival time of the filling
with this we can now come to the null
and the alternative hypothesis of the
log rank test
the null hypothesis is both groups have
identical distribution curves
and the alternative hypothesis is both
groups have different distribution
curves so as always with the statistical
hypothesis test you get a p-value at the
end of the log-rank test
the question is
whether this p-value is greater than the
significance level or not
the significance level is set to
0.05 in most cases
if the calculated p-value is greater
than
0.05
the null hypothesis is retained so based
on the available data it is assumed that
both groups have the same distribution
curve
if the p-value is smaller than 0.05
the null hypothesis is rejected
but how do i calculate the log rank test
i will now show you how to calculate the
log rank test online with data tab and
after that we will go through what the
formulas behind it are and how the log
rank test can be calculated by hand this
helps a lot in understanding it
for this we first go to datadeb.net and
copy our own data into this table
then you click on plus and click on the
survival analysis tab
we have here once a column with the time
and then a column that tells you whether
the event has occurred or not
here
1 stands for occurred and 0 stands for
censored
then we have the variable material with
the two materials a and b
depending on what you click here the
appropriate methods are calculated for
you
if you select only the variable time
the kaplan-meier survival curve is
displayed with the corresponding table
if no variable with status is given it
is assumed that no case is censored
if this is not the case you can simply
click here at status on the variable
that contains the data whether the event
has occurred or not
if you now select a factor for example
the material the log rank test will be
calculated
you can now read here the null and the
alternative hypothesis
the null hypothesis is there is no
difference between groups a and b in
terms of the distribution of time until
the event occurs
and the alternative hypothesis is there
is a difference between groups a and b
in terms of the distribution of time
until the event occurs
here below you can read the results
here you can see the p-value for the
log-rank test if you don't know exactly
how to interpret this
you can simply click on summary in words
a log rank test was calculated to see if
there was a difference between groups a
and b in terms of the distribution of
time
to event occurrence
for the present data the log rank tests
show that there is a difference between
the groups in terms of the distribution
of time until the event occurs
p smaller than 0.01
the null hypothesis is thus rejected
therefore if this p-value is greater
than the predefined significance level
which is in most cases five percent
the null hypothesis is retained that is
there is no difference
if the p-value is smaller then the null
hypothesis is rejected and it is assumed
based on available data that there is a
difference between the curves
and now i will show you how to calculate
the log rank test by hand
let's say we have group 1 and group 2
and we want to test if both groups have
the same survival time function
here we see the times when either an
event occurred or the respective case
was censored
1 means event occurred 0 means centered
if we look at our previous example with
the filling materials
then the groups would each have received
different material for the filling
let's say the time is in years
then for group 1 the first filling would
have failed after 2 years
the second filling after 3 years and so
on and so forth
in order to calculate a log rank test we
have to combine both tables
to do this we first note down all the
time points that occur in the groups
this is 2 3 4 6 7 and 8.
it is important that the times when only
sensored cases occurred are not included
in the table at time 5 one case was
censored but otherwise
5 does not occur so we do not include
time 5 in this table similar to the
kaplan-meier curve we now fill in the
columns m
q
and n for groups 1 and 2 respectively
m tells us for how many people an event
has occurred exactly at this point in
time
for group 1 after 2 years one feeling
has broken out after three years again
one feeling
at time four and six nothing has
happened
at time seven two fillings have broken
out and at time eight 1.
q tells us at which time how many cases
were censored
here we have only the time 5.
since we as already said did not take
over this time in the table
this value is assigned to the next
earlier time thus add 4 therefore a 1
stands here we can now do the same for
the second group
from the generated tables we can now
calculate the so-called expected values
for group 1 this is done with this
formula and for group 2 with that
formula
let's take a look at the first case n1
is 6 and n2 is also 6
therefore we have 6
divided by 6 plus 6
and m1 is 1 and m2 is 2
therefore we have 1 plus 2. this gives
us 1.5 we now do this for all the rows
and for both groups
now we need the observed values minus
the expected values for this we simply
calculate m1 minus e1 or m2 minus e2 we
get these values for each group
now we can calculate the so called log
rank statistic
for this we can take either the values
of group 1
or of group 2 we just take the values of
group 2.
o2 minus e2 is calculated by adding up
these values which is 1.15
but what is the variance of this
the variance is calculated with this
formula
so we first calculate for each row this
expression here and then we add it up in
our case we get
1.78
now we can calculate the log rank
statistic in our case we get
0.74
the log rank statistic is equivalent to
a chi-square value
therefore the critical p-value can be
determined via the chi-square
distribution
the required degrees of freedom are
given by the number of groups minus one
i hope you enjoyed the video and see you
next time
you